- ♪ THREE ALIENS
♪ CAME FROM THE SKY
♪ THE GALACTIC COUNCIL
SENT THEM ♪
- ♪ AND HERE'S THE REASON WHY
- ♪ THEIR MISSION IS TO STUDY
♪ EARTH'S MOST AVERAGE GUY
- ♪ TO SEE IF HUMANS
ARE WORTH SAVING ♪
♪ OR IF EVERYONE
HAS TO DIE ♪
- WAIT, WHAT?
I'M PRETTY SURE IT WAS CORKED
OR SOMETHING, MAN.
- OH, YEAH?
WELL, WHY'D YOU DRINK
3/4 OF IT?
- LOOK, I REALLY NEED
[chuckles]
THIS $5.00 BACK, OKAY?
IT'S BEEN A-A ROUGH
COUPLE MONTHS, MAN.
- JEFF?
- [yelps]
LINDA! YOU LOOK AMAZING.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN?
- I THINK THIS MIGHT BE
THE BUSIEST WEEK OF MY LIFE.
I'VE GOT A JOB INTERVIEW,
A DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT,
MY FRIEND'S BACHELORETTE--
- HEY, YOU WANNA GRAB LUNCH
OR COFFEE OR SOMETHING?
- UH!
- CHET!
- LET'S DRINK THIS BUBBLY
AND GET SNUGGLY.
- [laughs]
I'VE GOTTA GO.
- YEAH, I SHOULD PROBABLY GO.
I'VE GOT--I GOT
A PRETTY BUSY WEEK TOO.
[bird chirps]
[slurping]
[sobbing]
- HEY, MR. SNIFFLES.
WE GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL
FOR OUR FAVORITE SPECIAL GUY!
- I TOLD YOU GUYS
NO MORE SURPRISE GIFTS.
- WELL, SOMETHING TELLS ME
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE THIS ONE,
'CAUSE YOU'VE ALREADY LOVED HER
FOR FIVE YEARS!
- OH, MY GOD, NO!
WE NEED TO UNDO THIS
IMMEDIATELY!
- WELL, I GUESS I COULD
JUST CLEAR HER MEMORIES
FROM THE LAST 24 HOURS.
- AGH!
- OOPS.
- LINDA!
- OKAY, I SEE WHAT I DID.
- [sobbing]
OH, WHAT?
WHAT, IS SHE DEAD?
IS SHE DEAD?
- NO, NO, NO.
SHE'LL COME BACK TO
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS.
MAYBE A MONTH OR TWO, TOPS.
- OH, JESUS CHRIST.
SHE HAD SO MUCH IMPORTANT STUFF
TO DO THIS WEEK, GUYS.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
I DON'T KNOW.
ARE YOU SURE THIS IS GONNA WORK?
- TOTALLY.
- ARE YOU SURE
SHE'S GONNA BE OKAY?
- OH, FOR SURESIES.
[upbeat rock music]
- COME ON, LINDA.
- [groaning]
♪
[women shouting]
- COME ON, LINDA.
GET INTO IT!
- WHOO-HOO!
♪
AND I ALSO SPEAK
UN POQUITO...
DE ESP--
- WONDERFUL!
- [effeminate voice]
AND I'LL HAVE
THE 32-OUNCE ANGUS STEAK,
UH, RARE.
- WHOA!
[laughs]
YOU'RE NOT PREGNANT,
ARE YOU, BABE?
I KEEP TELLING YOU
IT ISN'T AN EFFECTIVE FORM
OF BIRTH CONTROL
TO SHOOT IT ALL
OVER YOUR FACE EVERY TIME.
BUT YOU JUST WON'T LISTEN
TO ME.
- [Jeff's voice]
I'M NOT PREGNANT, OKAY?
CAN WE PLEASE TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE?
- YIKES!
WHAT'S UP WITH YOUR VOICE?
YOU GOT A SORE THROAT?
OR SOMETHING?
- [coughs]
YEAH, YEAH.
I, UH, I THINK I DO.
- I TOLD YOU, YOU GOTTA STOP
DEEP-THROATING ME SO MUCH.
BUT YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO HAVE IT
YOUR WAY, DON'T YOU?
- HEY, DUDE,
THIS ISN'T APPROPRIATE
DINNER CONVERSATION,
ALL RIGHT?
LOOK, I THINK WE SHOULD
BREAK UP.
I'M STILL IN LOVE WITH JEFF.
- WHAT? JEFF?
YOU SAID HIS DICK WAS SO SMALL,
YOU GOT--
- THAT'S A LIE!
I NEVER SAID
JEFF'S DICK WAS SMALL!
- TAKE IT EASY, BABE!
- YOU [bleep] LIAR!
- I WON'T HIT A WOMAN--
- OH! OH!
- OH!
OKAY! THAT'S IT.
GAH!
GAH! AAH!
[wailing]
I'M A BAD PERSON!
- I CAN'T BELIEVE I DON'T
REMEMBER ANY OF THIS.
- YEAH.
I GUESS HE MUST'VE HIT YOU
PRETTY HARD.
[slurps]
[cell phone rings]
- HELLO?
- HI, LINDA.
IT'S DR. LYNN.
UH, WE'RE GONNA NEED YOU
TO COME IN FOR A FOLLOW-UP.